what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we're going to
be talking about the ending of Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 and the two
post-credits scenes so if you have not
seen the movie yet and you care this is
your warning we are talking about it all
in this video and there's a lot to talk
about so we are going to Dive Right In
at the end of Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol 3. we saw the disbandment of the
Guardians team that we've known and
loved over the past decade it is
definitely sad however the second
post-credit scene gives us hope that
perhaps the Guardians team will reunite
one day but we'll get into that in a bit
now throughout the movie mantis who we
discovered in the Guardians of the
Galaxy holiday special is the
half-sister of Peter has been trying to
convince Peter to go back to Earth to
visit his grandfather because he just
left and that his grandfather was
morning at the time too over the loss of
his daughter and Peter's mother
eventually at the end of the movie Peter
decides that this is indeed what he's
going to do he returns to Earth where he
has actually been back before in
Avengers end game although since he was
always trying to avoid going back and
speaking to his grandfather that
probably was never an option for him so
he simply left with the Guardians and
Thor but now that he saved the Galaxy
once more he goes back to Earth he goes
back to his old home or his
grandfather's old home either way he
knew where it was he goes to the door to
see a caretaker he thinks it's the wrong
house but the caretaker says no he is
inside so he goes in and he goes out to
the back and he sees his grandfather and
probably to his surprise his grandfather
instantly recognizes who he is and
Embraces him in a huge hug Peter has
been missing for years upon years upon
years at this point in time his
grandfather never knew what happened to
him probably thought he was dead but of
course in the back of his head the
entire time was hoping that he would
eventually return home so Peter goes off
back to Earth and lives with his
grandfather then we have mantis who
decides that it's time for her and her
new little adorable fluffy babies to go
out in the galaxy and kind of find her
own way we get a really sad part where
Drax wants to go with with her the two
of them have obviously bonded throughout
the entire film we hear mantis stick up
for Drax but sadly mantis says no I have
to do this by myself this is my own
destiny this is my own Journey Drax is
super upset however nebula tells him
that she needs him there in nowhere due
to Nowhere having a ton of new children
and animals in their population now
nebula needs help running the city since
the Guardians of the Galaxy now own it
we see nebula kind of have a change of
heart about Drax and instead of being
mean to him she says that I finally saw
who you are you are a father this of
course comes after Drax helped all of
the little kids and communicated with
them and helped them all escape from the
high evolutionary so Drax agrees to stay
behind and help nebula with all the new
children and new animals on nowhere now
of course this Gamora that we have in
this movie was never really the true
Gamora that has been with the Guardians
in Guardians 1 and Guardians 2. and
since it wasn't the same it was kind of
not in the cards for Peter and quill to
ultimately end up together but Peter
makes peace with this and Gamora goes
back with The ravengers Rock it is then
really upset that these Guardians his
family his friends are leaving and he
says this is the end of the Guardians No
One's Gonna lead them anymore in which
the team of course all looks to Rocket
and they say no you are going to lead
them you are the leader of the Guardians
of the Galaxy the universe is always
going to need its Guardians so therefore
you have to keep the team together and
it's your destiny to lead them and that
takes us into the first post-credits
scene the new Guardians of the Galaxy
team however I'm not actually sure
they're going to be called The Guardians
of the Galaxy based off of the
characters that we have on this team I'm
actually thinking it's a brand new team
with a different name that we've seen in
the comics before and don't worry we're
gonna dive into that but first big thank
you to our sponsors Marvel's Guardians
of the Galaxy video game if you're sad
that the MCU Guardians of the Galaxy
Trilogy has ended here's something that
will satisfy your craving for more
Guardians now I know most people have
probably heard about this game but
Marvel's Guardians of the Galaxy is a
single player story driven action
adventure game out now for PlayStation
and Xbox consoles and PC I've been
hearing people Rave about this game for
a while it won best narrative at the
game awards in 2021 and now that I've
played it I definitely understand why it
is awesome this game is set in a
completely new and original Universe
these aren't the Guardians from the
comics or the movies but they're
inspired by both so they feel fresh and
familiar at the same time it's a fun and
epic story but it also has a lot of
heart with deep character arcs that
highlight the personalities of the
Guardians you get to spend 20 hours with
those Guardians so you get to see and
experience them in a way that you never
have before now the whole game is about
you playing as Star-Lord and trying to
lead the Guardians they all feel like
living breathing characters so you truly
get to experience something really
unique in being their leader pulling the
shots and trying to bring those strong
personalities together it really makes
you feel for what Star-Lord has to do
now of course you know that one of the
greatest things about the Guardians is
the music this game features a massive
soundtrack from an epic orchestral score
to classic 80s tracks and an original
Rock album created just for the game the
game includes many outfits for the
Guardians inspired by the comics and the
MCU including suits inspired by the 2008
Guardians of the Galaxy Comics just like
in Guardians volume 3. get your copy by
clicking the link in the description
down below
now the first post-credit scene takes us
to another planet where we see our new
Guardians of the Galaxy team and
everybody is wearing the new Guardians
uniforms this new team consists of of
course their new leader Rocket Raccoon
King Groot Cosmo the dog who was awesome
in the movie Adam Warlock craglin and
Phila Vel now this post-credit scene is
pretty straightforward it's simply
showing us that there is indeed a new
Guardians of the Galaxy team just
because the original members kind of
went their own ways doesn't mean the
team itself falls apart they have a cool
little reference to music which always
plays a huge part in the Guardians of
the Galaxy movies they're talking about
what their favorite songs are and then
before they go into battle rocket plays
come and get your love by Redbone which
is a direct callback to the very first
opening of the very first Guardians of
the Galaxy movie then we see our new
Guardians of the Galaxy team run into
the fight however like I mentioned there
is a little bit more to this there was a
plot leak that was going around that
actually was very accurate about this
scene however they called this team the
annihilators now what's really
interesting about this is that Adam
Warlock was a part of this group but it
also had some other crazy cool
characters like the Silver Surfer who is
said to be coming to the MCU relatively
soon getting his own special
presentation perhaps after the Fantastic
Four film also Beta Ray Bill was a part
of this team as well and hopefully we'll
get betray bill in the MCU at some point
in time we've already seen an Easter egg
for him so he's out there somewhere also
Nova is a part of the team as well who I
thought might have been teased in this
movie but unfortunately was wrong about
but there obviously is a president's
here for the annihilators to be an
actual team in the MCU however they were
originally formed to take on Thanos and
we know that Thanos is no longer around
however with the Multiverse anything is
possible so as of right now this is our
new guardian's team however they could
eventually go by the annihilators now we
know most of the people that are on this
team except for phyla Bell she was
introduced in this movie and she was one
of the almost perfect subjects that the
high evolutionary created in the trailer
and in the movie we can see her running
around sort of a hamster will in the
high evolutionary talk about how she's
been running for hours doesn't get tired
can survive for a few weeks off of only
about 30 calories basically she is the
evolution she is the perfect specimen
just about she is now part of the
Guardians of the Galaxy team since they
helped rescue her and the rest of her
brothers and sisters that's what we'll
call them however it's pretty
interesting in the comics phylavel is a
Cree there are a few different versions
of her because she does appear in a
couple of different universes but
basically she is the genetically
engineered daughter of the cree Marbell
and Phila Bell would eventually go on to
become Captain Marvel herself so
obviously here they have kind of changed
a little bit about her however the part
about her being genetically engineered
seems to be the same thanks to the high
evolutionary however it doesn't seem
like she is going to be Cree unless the
high evolutionary actually managed to
steal her from the cree but no doubt
she's going to be a big player moving
forward in the MCU and also we've
noticed that her eyes do glow purple
which is a sign of cosmic energy so I'm
also imagining that she's going to be
pretty powerful as well now the second
post-credit scene there isn't much to
this but there is one big main point
that Marvel Studios wants us to know
however there could actually be a pretty
big multiversal tease here we cut back
to Peter Quill and his grandpa we have a
fun little Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special Easter egg as the
newspaper says that Kevin Bacon was
kidnapped we have some fun banter
between them Peter Quill is arguing
about chores again nothing really
insanely important about this scene or
the dialogue however what is important
comes next after the scene we see a
white screen and it says the legendary
Star-Lord will return now this has a lot
of theories surrounding it right now and
I gotta say I'm with the Multiverse
theory on this and I'll explain I've
seen this rumor and theory around online
a lot I think my buddy Paul over at
heavy spoilers was the first person to
come up with this so I'll give him full
credit on this but normally when Marvel
Studio says that a character will return
it's a black background with white
letters however this is the opposite
it's a white background with black
letters and we know that Marvel Studios
typically not all the time but typically
does everything with intention so the
theory around this is starlord will
return but perhaps it's going to be a
variant of Star-Lord perhaps we are
going to see a Star-Lord again in the
MCU it just won't happen to be this
particular Star-Lord after all we do
know in secret Wars universes are going
to collide and variants are going to
interact with each other so perhaps
we're going to see different variants of
Star-Lord they still could be played by
Chris Pratt or they could be played by
somebody else but since we are getting
closer to Secret Wars this could mean
something after all an Ant-Man Quantum
Mania it said King will return but again
it was black background with white
letters it is also worth noting that the
legendary Star-Lord was a comic run
where Star-Lord went solo so perhaps
since he's left the Guardians now and
he's on Earth he could actually get his
own solo story Chris Pratt did say that
he would come back that it wasn't off
the table so maybe that's something that
we could be getting a Star Wars kind of
solo Adventure in until eventually he
reunites with the Guardians and Avengers
Secret Wars I am assuming a lot of
people are going to reunite in secret
Wars since basically the entire universe
and of course the heroes on earth have
to come together and they have to go to
other universes and combine with them
and team up with them to defeat King the
Conqueror and all of his variants so I'm
thinking a reunion for the Guardians of
the Galaxy the true original team could
be set up for the future in secret Wars
but we'll have to wait and see on that
in the meantime they're off doing their
own things and we have a new Guardians
of the Galaxy team so that was it for
the ending explained and post-credits
explained please let me know what you
thought about the movie and this video
in the post credits down below also
don't forget to like the video subscribe
and leave a comment so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month don't forget to follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof